as always our recordings of our virtual
meetups will be available on youtube
about a week after the meetup and we'll
post a message on meetup when the
recording is ready
i am very pleased to introduce our
speaker today dr stephen gary is a
physical oceanographer and climate
scientist with 15 years of experience
observing and modeling the north
atlantic ocean
in his current role at parallel works
stefan provides with
stefan works with platform users to
develop workflows in parcel in other
frameworks for earth and environmental
science applications including machine
learning he has also taught
undergraduates and graduate students in
the u.s and in scotland
today
you could ask questions at any time
you can use the chat or you can use the
raise hand feature in zoom or you're
welcome to mute yourself um if you do
any of the form or two um i'll interrupt
our speaker um with your question so
feel free to ask at any time and i'll
pass it to him
well rebecca thank you very much for
that introduction
hello everybody um i'm gonna switch over
to screen sharing
okay there we go
and
great
um and yeah
so i'm i'm really excited about
presenting this talk uh because as
rebecca noted i'm an oceanographer but
i'm also
uh
sort of within the last year i started
uh full-time at parallel works and and
went from
uh sort of an academic track um into
industry
and i've really been enjoying working
with scientists listening to what they
have to say and saying oh i know how to
find a solution for that um and so
hopefully this is a some opportunities
to see some solutions uh so we're going
to talk about python based machine
learning and high performance computing
workflows
um and this is in collaboration with uh
my principally four other colleagues at
parallel works um
and so that's alvaro vidal torreira uh
michael wilde and um matthew shaxted um
and
we are
i put my my contact information down at
the bottom of the slide
uh we already have a question anna asks
is michael wilde from argonne
uh yeah he he was uh well he's on i
don't know if he's still affiliated or
on leave but at one point he was there
yes
um
and
so okay so i will switch to the next
so uh here's a brief outline um i'd like
to start with a motivation a challenge
and some definitions uh so that we're
all on the same page
um and then i'd like to prevent present
a solution to to this to this challenge
and that is parcel the the parcel
parallel scripting uh
library for use in python
and then i'm going to go through sort of
three examples or use cases of parcel uh
we'll start with a a
simple jupyter notebook that sends jobs
to the cloud
and the take-home point there is that
parcel
code can be used to broadcast a
calculation
uh the second example will be uh some
recent work using scikit-learn and
parcel
and uh and some lessons learned there
then would look a little bit at an idea
for using
uh uh
sort of integrating a workflow with uh
machine learning integrating machine
learning and a large scale
cfd so it'd be computational fluid
dynamics app
uh into a workflow
as sort of a potential uh
uh
and a building on the the previous
example
and then i've got some ideas for the
future uh
so uh some things that uh are currently
some new function app new functionality
that's currently being worked on
uh they including things like uh
clusters in the cloud and mixing and
matching resources to better match the
computational task
and so i wanted to start with uh some
motivation and that is global innovation
is driven by by modeling and simulation
in that there are many many applications
that
we would that are in our everyday lives
that are at one point were modeled by a
super computer um and these uh the
application these apps that are running
within the super computer are often uh
applicate their codes that have been
built up over the course of many many
years through scientific experience and
and so
they are uh well established but also
very very general they can be used for
many different things so for example
uh a computational fluid dynamics code
may be used to simulate an airplane
could be completely reconfigured to
think to simulate uh flow in a city
um and so there's a lot of uh
the
simulation has
has a has a direct impact in our in our
everyday lives
and
and what i what i wanted to do was to
draw on focus on some real world case
studies
to think about
what these apps are like and how we can
interact with these really large
uh really large potentially complicated
programs
and and how
we can streamline them to make them easy
to use easier to use
um and so what i'd like to focus on is a
little bit of
sort of an example from weather
forecasting uh ocean currents moving
stuff
uh river ecosystems
and then uh a last a last idea about
industrial design optimization so this
is these are the the kinds of the kinds
of so these are the specific things that
i get that i can speak to today
um
and
to to sort of think about the challenge
uh so i mentioned these apps are these
you know whether it is a
a computational flow dynamics code or a
uh
chemistry a a a molecule simulator
or a weather forecast model uh users
often approach these codes with with
some trepidation interpretation in the
sense that they can be they can appear
like the tiger on the on the the
the left side which is you know scary
there lots can go wrong it needs huge
resources to run
and uh and so it can be a sort of a very
daunting task
but the point that i want to make is
that
it's much more manageable if you provide
it with four things
uh these four key things would be
uh and
and so it becomes becomes something
more like a kitten on the on the right
side
where
uh and i'm i mean his analogy would be
like talking about you know providing
shelter food
uh love
and uh
and and a laser pointer right so the
idea is to ensure that you have
computational resources to house that
app
you've got data to feed it you have a
configuration which is telling which is
setting it up in in the right way and
then a laser pointer is telling it when
to launch when to go
um and so more specifically
there we go
um oh to make sort of concrete examples
for what i mean by computer resources so
for starting the compute resources we
might go to the cloud and use gcloud to
create a compute instance
for data on that compute instance we
might mount an nfs file system or we
might copy over files use it from a
cloud bucket using gsutil
for a configuration that would usually
be a configuration file that would
include
app specific parameterizations like
the grid over which the numerical
weather model is run or the type of
physics package that is used to simulate
the clouds in the model
and the last part
would be the launch would be the exact
command that is used to invoke and and
to run that that app so in this if it's
uh if it's a containerized app if it's
in docker
then it would be for example docker run
the the application
now
that's this is nice what we really want
to do though is is take it even one step
further which is
even for numerical weather models
wanting running one model isn't enough
we need to run an ensemble of models
that are all started with different
initial conditions so we can understand
for example the the sensitivity to
initial conditions
and so we end up with a situation that
looks like this
where we don't just have one
one kitten we don't just have one
contained application we are really
trying to manage
a whole flock
of of app of simultaneous simulations
that are running together
because the and this occurs for weather
forecasting but it also occurs for many
other apps because it's important to
uh determine the sensitivity of the
application to a range of parameters uh
that it could be running under to better
understand what the simulation was also
going to be
so
you know the the idea is
to
uh
and so it's essential that we we
coordinate things right so i bet you
weren't expecting to come to a talk
where i was going to say that herding
kittens is possible
and uh but it is and and so now we're
going to dive into the specifics of how
how we can do this and how we can manage
all this and and keep everything all uh
coordinated
and so this coordination process or
orchestration process is a workflow
and the workflow is used in many
different contexts in many different
ways and so i wanted to to put it here
to to to to describe exactly what i mean
uh by a workflow in this context
the slide is divided into two zones uh
the top row would be considered
consistent with uh
what what i would call
persistent resources so that would be
your local computer that could be the
laptop that's sitting in front of you it
could be a login node on a on a slurm
cluster or it could be for example if
you're on the uh you have a user
container that's on the the parallel
works platform
which we'll see we'll see for a demo in
a moment
the the other persistent resource would
be your storage so like could be a cloud
bucket or a file system on a cluster
um it could even be something on your
local computer as well
um and the the last uh key thing would
be a an image or a container registry so
this is where you're going to be housing
the the source code um
or the the bulk of the model would be
would be in the in these locations now
not every app is going to use
each one of these different things but
these are things that a large app will
often touch on
uh so in our case for a weather forecast
model
it's going to pull from each one of
these these different things
um
so the order at which then so then the
bottom part of the slide are the what i
would classify as sort of temporary
resources so this would be
the worker nodes that are actually going
to go through the process of running the
calculation
and they get spun up right before the
job is needed so that would be step one
where they they get they get started
uh then
the the config the setup and the launch
so that would be the the
the love and the
uh the the food and the laser pointer
for the kitten
would then get ssh those are would be
say usually they can be up to three or
more separate files that would get sent
to the worker node
the third step would be to mount or to
copy data to the worker node that it
would use and then the fourth step would
be to copy an image or a container there
for for to be run on the worker node
once those pieces are in place then the
simulation can be started
the output is generated on the worker
node and then it gets sent back up into
that persistent space whether it goes to
the cloud storage or whether it goes to
your local computer that's up to you to
to the to the author to choose
now this is fine as i mentioned earlier
we're going from not just one kitten
but we're really interested in
potentially two apps stringing one
application one after the next so i put
these uh
these pipes going into the top of the
second worker node to indicate that it
too is going to be pulling from your
local computer from the storage and from
the container or the image registry
um
and and and so on you could even chain
more of them down the down the line and
that would make for a progressively more
complicated workflow
but these same steps would apply
the
other uh dimension that we can add to
this
is to think about
uh running
not just
one single instance of a workflow where
you're going from app one to app two and
so on but there's actually going to be
uh
you know multiple instances running at
the same time so in the case of the
weather forecast model
the app one would be to create the
forecast the second app would be to run
post processing
the third app might be to do some
machine learning on that
and finally send it
send its output
so
how do how do we orchestrate all this
and
what
what uh what i'd like to propose today
is is is is uh and
uh in some and and also demonstrate
is using the the parcel parallel
scripting uh uh package which is in in
in uh it's written in python it's for
python
uh and it's written by the the parcel
project team
the uh you can install it with uh pip
install parcel there's it's also
available with for for conda
um
there's this slide is divided into two
parts where there's some example code on
the f on the right and some some
information on the left i'd really like
you to focus on the information on the
left first
and
and there
the the really beautiful thing
about
uh about parcel is that
there's just two kinds there's two kinds
of of apps in parcel
parcel will
either create what it's called it will a
python app
by
with the python app decorator
that you can see on the on the on the
right side in the top
and there's also a bash app which is all
created with a separate bash app
decorator
and python apps we'll call python
functions
uh bash apps can be used to call
external applications so you can have it
run a shell command or you can have it
run
uh you can tell it to docker run
something
or you you know at any executable that
you have access to in a normal shell you
can run with the bash app
um now we're launching
the the examples here are super simple
they're tiny little things that run
very very quickly uh we're what we
really want to do is replace the hello
world
line there with run weather forecast
model
and
what happens is this it can take hours
to run you know these large simulations
and so
the the what what these what these apps
return are futures they are python
objects that
represent the results
when it is realized
and so in your code you can keep pinging
that object that's returned from the
function and say are you ready yet are
you ready yet um or you can even halt
execution and wait for execution will
wait until a certain future is ready and
then it can proceed
um now if you if you don't ask for the
future to realize itself
the
each app just basically gets pushed
and it runs
and you can run multiple apps
concurrently
um and so the idea is that
if this allows for parallelization
because you could write a for loop
around
this one of these decorated apps
and and each instance will then just be
pushed out to run and they'll run in
parallel and then when you ask for their
futures you're then asking for all of
them to finish
or you're waiting you're asking the
execution to wait until everything is
finished
um and because they're in python it's uh
very very flexible and it really it
really does work with uh
write once run anywhere approach
how how would we
this is this this so
the previous slide showed an individual
app
uh
and they didn't show uh how they can be
chained together which is one of the key
challenges that was described in the
previous schematics
and so
uh this there's the next two slides are
going to show
we're gonna provide a concrete example
for how
apps can be chained together
uh uh through by through parcel um so
for example we're gonna have three steps
in in our workflow we might have a
simulation step oops i'm sorry
there'll be a simulation step that's the
first bash app
uh and all it does is it's a wrapper for
running an executable file
that writes its outputs
the
uh
there's a second step which will merge
all the inputs
and send it to the outputs
and that's also a bash app it's got this
it's got an executable
called merge
it will take
these inputs that are in the in in one
and it'll merge everything and write it
out to
uh the
out to zero
oh i'm sorry i keep missing
the screen
okay
the the last uh app would be one of
analyze
where the
inputs
from the previous step are going to be
uh
run through some kind of python analysis
package and notice that this is a python
app and not a bash app so
it's there's there's no quotes in it to
make to send it as a string
so it's just this this last one is just
python code
so this is the stage where the apps are
defined
[Music]
what we have to do is we actually need
to execute them
and so this would be the workflow code
where
so for example
we are the simulate
the simulate function
is has been decorated with the
bash the parcel bash app
so
it's not just it's not just a python
function this this this thing is being
interpreted by parcel as something
special something to paralyze
and so
by iterating over a loop
parcel will see that
multiple instances are that are being
created it will then send that job offer
execution but it will allow other jobs
it will allow multiple instances of that
simulate function to be called
and
the sims dot append is sims is just a
list of the futures that are being
returned by the simulate the simulation
so this is exactly what a weather
forecast
uh
uh ensemble would do
is it's it's going to run
maybe
20
80 different weather forecasts with
slightly different initial conditions
and they're all going to ideally run in
parallel at the same time
uh the
next step is we need to analyze the data
and so here we would for example use the
second bash app that we defined to merge
all
the inputs from all the all the outputs
from the simulation so that's
you'll notice that outputs
here
is being set to the inputs for the merge
the merge uh the merge
app
um
and then it is defining new outputs
uh
f for for its output
and so uh
what it'll do is it'll first merge all
the inputs
and then it'll send it'll send
all those
merged inputs
i'm sorry i'll merge all the outputs
it'll send all those merged outputs
as inputs to the analyze bash app i'm
sorry the analyze python app
so there's
that's the third step in the process
when we call this whole thing
and we enforce the result
that's when we say we want all these
futures to realize at this point
and so execution will
work its way through and then execution
will wait until that final result is
ready
find this
okay
great so what we'll do in a few minutes
is i'll show an actual example of code
as it runs
um and and uh and we can we can see
uh
we can uh and and so as the second a
second approach
may help may help clarify that as well
in the code in the example that i run
there will be a single just a single app
um
a very important thing to note about
parcel is that
it needs to be configured very carefully
well i mean it needs a configuration in
order to run on these resources so for
example if you were to run parcel on a
slurm cluster
uh you would need to
uh
define
this this this this chain here would go
you have to set and what parcel calls in
an exit executor
and then you need to select the slurm
provider
within this therm provider you would
input critical information about your
slurm cluster like the partition or your
username or the host where you would log
into it
and you can also define things like the
course per node or the memory on the
node
and whether or not you want it to be
like exclusive use of of of that
particular node so these are all kind of
classic things that would normally be
defined
uh
with uh
with like s run commands but here parcel
includes that within a configuration
that is loaded within parcel right right
right after it's been all set right here
at the bottom
um and we also set uh storage access to
basically say how to rsync files back to
the the starting point
so
i met i've been mentioning you know this
is this would be a configuration for a
uh a slurm cluster which is sort of a
traditional cluster
the
other uh for a cloud situation parcel
can also be configured to run for
example in this case on google cloud
um it would look it would have a very
similar kind of configuration
but there's different things in
different places because google cloud
calls things differently than what alarm
cluster would so for example
uh
you would need instead of a username
and a login you would provide a key file
and a project uh id
um you need to tell it what region to
run in and for example the instance type
this would be an n1
n1 standard one this would be a one cpu
machine a fairly small instance but you
can make that
larger uh
a larger instance as well
and
uh so similarly all these things are
loaded into the configuration and then
that configuration is then uh loaded
into parcel
so this tells parcel effectively what
kind of hardware to use
so
what i'd like to do is show this with a
live demo
um before i jump into code though i
thought it'd be useful to have a process
flow diagram so that you can see what
we're about to do before we actually do
it
um
i'm going to uh use a an app called
ocean parcels
it's uh for you it's it's it's it's an
oceanographic application used for uh
calculating the particle trajectories
based on ocean currents so imagine
something drifting in the sea whether
it's microplastics or whether it's a
baby fish or whether it's potentially
oil an oil spill how does that move
based on the movement of the currents
um
and we're going to jump to the parallel
works platform there's a user container
there where if
each user has their own files they have
an integrated development environment
and it's notebook aware so right away
you'll be able to double click on a on a
notebook file the notebook pops up
and in that notebook we're going to run
some local tasks right there in the in
the in the user container
but then
we're gonna we're gonna run
some larger tasks that go out to the
cloud workers
and
those tasks are
going to send a configuration and a
launch information
so it'll be one kind of configuration
config one to one worker it's going to
run that
configuration it's going to run
those particular particles that are
assigned in that configuration
and then it's going to send over a
different config file that has different
particle starting locations
to a different worker so they're both
doing different calculations but they're
using the same app to do the same
calculation
and then when the workers are done
they're going to rsync their results
back to the platform
and one key thing that uh
that i that
i've already started
are the i've already started the
resources on this so there are
the two workers that we're going to use
have already been spun up
um and i've done that in advance because
uh just to make the workflow run a
little faster uh during during the talk
um
and the other thing that uh that is that
is nice
that the the parallel works platform
provides is
it will
uh all the the resource configurations
that i just mentioned before those are
stored in a very uh intuitive graphical
user interface
and that's stored in a pw.conf file so
this is a resource configuration file
and that is sent the notebook loads that
instead of having to store all this
information about the the parcel config
that i showed in the two previous slides
uh oh so i'm going to jump to that so
there we go switch tabs
all right
so
this is uh the user container
uh integrated development environment on
the parallelworks platform you'll notice
it's displaying a jupiter notebook in
the center and off to the side
is the are the files that this user has
access to
um everything that i do in this demo
could also be done
say from your laptop
but it would not have
the ease of access and the the
the same uh the same abstraction
that that you're about to see here
um
so
i provided a preamble with kind of what
we're doing we've kind of gone over
the key thing is we're going to start
with some local calculations
and on the
right hand side you'll see a couple
files will pop up these will be png
files because it's making some plots
so we'll just run that
and it's so there it's running
and we'll see some png files created on
the
left side and that's great uh but
unfortunately my great science is uh it
needs to run faster than that so i can't
just wait for these uh these files to be
generated slowly i'm going to break this
whole calculation out into the cloud
and so
here is here's where we're going to use
parcel to parallelize this process
um
you'll notice that i'm loading
a config here and this is the same as
the config as before except this is the
the parallel works configuration
uh but it's in the same same in spirit
uh as the slides that i showed before
so i've loaded the configuration
i've now defined
my
my bash app so there's only one app in
this workflow
um and
like the slides at the beginning of the
talk there's there's a config file
that's being sent to to the worker
that's saying which particles to launch
where
there's the actual launcher file
and that that is basically a docker run
statement
and then i'm telling it where to write
to so it's going to create an animated
gif file
um and the run command is built up here
where the launcher this is a docker run
statement
it's going to use it's going to use
python as an interpreter and the config
is really a script that is being fed
into the container to execute
this run command is the first item that
gets put into the string this this the
string that gets executed as a as a bash
uh as a as a bash shell
um and it will then make a directory
locally
move the output
into that directory
and
because that and then and then it and
then i'll show you in just a moment how
it knows to rsync it back to the
platform
or or to your local machine
so i'll just i'll run that cell
and now
this is the workflow stage so we've
defined the bash app above
and
run ocean parcels is the app we defined
that's right here
what i need to do is feed it the inputs
and and i need to tell it what the
inputs and outputs are
and so that's what i've done with these
lines at the top
so
what i'm doing is i'm telling it i want
you to use
these two config files
uh test ocean parcels one test ocean
parcels two
i want you for the launcher i want you
to use wrap the wrap docker script which
is basically a script that just says
docker run
and
i'm specifying the out directory as this
this uh for for this for this for this
talk here
um
and each one of these things is pre it
has is fed into the path object which
basically returns the path of this of
this file
whether it's on the local machine or
whether it's on
the remote cloud worker so this is how
parcel can keep track of what's
uh what you have of your path
where you are here and your path on the
on the cloud worker
and so what you'll see on the left side
here is you'll see a couple log files
being added to the actual workflow
directory
and then up at the top
we'll see the uh
the the these animated gifs that are
created by
the the workflow they'll be put into the
storage at the top
so let's run
and so we're all we're doing is we're
looping over
for each configuration in this list of
configurations we're running ocean
parcels it sent that out to the workers
um
the
and it's just appending the futures
and execution is stopping and waiting
right here where i'm calling for the
result of these
futures
you notice that it's a little asterisk
is still up here in this cell
as it waits for those cloud workers to
go
zoom window over so you can see when
oh there we go it's already sent its
outputs
into the folder
uh in pi data chicago
and so i have
one output file from the first worker
and output file from the second worker
the files are
a com
series of png files that have been
squashed together into a single gif
and the point here is it shows
that
config one where it was particles that
have been launched all in the
uh
western part of the domain
the second config are particles that
were launched in the eastern part of the
domain there are two different
calculations that were run in different
places of course i could merge these
results and make a single figure
but i'm showing them separately so that
you can see they were indeed run
in parallel independent of each other
the
uh another perspective and so yeah this
is the southern southern tip of africa
uh with the uh the egalis current that's
moving uh particles around
with you can see a very very strong
red
uh currents there with those big arrows
and then a lot of other turbulence
around it
on the platform i can keep track of the
number of workers that i have access to
so this is a different tab since i don't
want to disturb the image
um
oh and i'm going to change the zoom
there we go um this this bar
here tells me how many workers i have
set up for this demo
um i moved the sliders around to adjust
the minimum and maximum workers
and so so that everything would spin up
quickly for today i had the slider set
all the way
to two
um if i move it back to zero it'll go
through the worker auto shutdown
sequence in in a few minutes or a minute
or two
um so this is a nice way to keep track
of resources that are on or off
since we finished our demo i'm going to
turn it off the resource
and we'll go back to the talk
okay
so the ocean parcel demo was a nice a
nice starting point because it it goes
through this process of
of defining an app
uh and
as uh as a as a parcel app
um it sends it the the config and launch
information it runs it and it sends the
results back
uh but now
there's you know we've got more
complicated things to do
um and so let's take a look at
another application that we've worked
with
um
so
here's an example from uh
river river or hydrology uh we want to
study
uh we want to know
how much
uh what the respiration rate is in river
ecosystems so
this is basic that respiration rate is
how much food is converted to co2 within
the river in particular within the
sediment
and this is really important for
two reasons there's a climate impacts or
uh
generation of co2
there's also
uh it's it's a good way to measure the
net effect of the microbial activity
uh in the in the sediment and that can
be have really important impacts for
thinking about pollution in rivers
um and uh
and uh and and whether the river is a is
a healthy ecosystem
so
uh there's
sort of two ways to go about it right
you can go to a river
and you can get a flask of water and you
can measure the production of co2
uh the change in rate of co2 per hour
that's coming out of that flask
the
other the other way uh so but those
those observations are very very
expensive
and very difficult to maintain are not
but they're very difficult to obtain
and so instead what we'd really like to
do is use in a database of these
measurements
and
train a machine learning model to
predict what the respiration rate would
be
given
the environmental metadata at that
location so at this stream
we know what its large-scale
characteristics are based on satellite
data
so if we can train a machine learning
model
to predict respiration rate based on
what the satellite says at that area
we can then make predictions of
respiration rate
at any other river that the satellite
has seen
that's a that's the that's the general
approach
now this is exciting however there in
addition oops
in addition
sorry about that in addition to the fact
that
uh there is there's there's not tons and
tons of data to to work with
the
really big challenges are that there's
lots of machine learning models to
choose from
and
each machine learning model may have
different hyper parameters that has to
be fit in addition to the model
parameters themselves
so
what we're doing what we've what we've
done is we've opted to use
uh an approach where we just use every
model we can find
and
optimize all of those models hyper
parameters
so a schematic would look something like
this
on the left
column
or left side of the slide is
a
what would be an input data set so it's
like uh it's like a a csv file or like a
almost like a spreadsheet where each row
is an observation
then each column would be a variable
there's the columns on the
left side are going to be inputs to the
machine learning the columns on the
right side would be the outputs
and so basically what we want to do is
use the features the left side of the
data set to predict the right side of
the data set and there's lots of
different
models that will be able to
that we can fit to this data to do that
and so
instead of just selecting one
we use up to 14 of them
and each model may have its own hyper
parameters
so we have to fit
each model
a certain number of times
we select the model with the best hyper
parameters
and then we stack
all those results together
into a single prediction so we have
these 14 best models
with the with their best hyper
parameters and we use all of their
predictions we stack them together to
get a single result at the very end
as you can see this is a tremendous
number of uh
of different actions that are all
happening and they need to be
coordinated together in a workflow
pattern
so
uh what we did is we this whole this
whole workflow is set up with a form at
the beginning of it so that it's fairly
straightforward for users to run
so we would give it the input file
this is that that row that
that spreadsheet
with rows and columns
we would tell it what the number of
inputs would be
we give it a configuration file
and whether or not it wanted to run this
hyper parameter
optimization or not
and
over what it can do is it get it gets
fit
it uses the environmental metadata that
metadata that it has
at each of these sites where we know the
respiration rate
and it then uses it then is able to then
predict
respiration rate at other sites and so
we started with
180 data set data points
but
we've made predictions at many many
other sites you can see all across well
this is just to zoom in on the
continental us we've also done it
globally with other databases
and in the process though we learned
that the scikit-learn which is the
framework we've used here which is
written in python we would expect it to
have lend itself well to parcel
but the pipeline objects within
scikit-learn are very difficult to
separate from each other
and so what we've had to do instead was
use
uh
use parcel to launch the whole thing
but when it to launch the whole super
learner but when it's running it's
actually running in parallel thanks to
desk orchestration or its own built-in
uh parallelization
so what the lesson learned here is that
sometimes the parallelization framework
that's used is inextricably tied to the
app
um
but
uh just to note uh i mentioned uh
industrial design optimization and
this is
this is an opportunity to
even though the internal aspects of the
super learner are all are going to be
difficult to paralyze using parcel if we
the whole the super learner as a whole
can be viewed as a single app
and then it
can be then orchestrated within the rest
of within a parcel orchestrated workflow
so for example this is this would this
would be uh
an engine design optimization
uh a very very simplified schematic of
of
of of this optimization where if there
are very expensive models to run a
simulation within an engine
we'd use the super learner to model that
engine behavior
to create what would be called like a
surrogate model or a much lighter weight
model that behaves almost the same way
as the big model but it's just a machine
learning model
and we can use that much lighter weight
model to predict what the behavior of
the machine learning model or what the
engine a big model would be like over a
very wide parameter suite and then we
can go through and iterate the design
process
and here the super learner could be
deployed with parcel if it's treated
as a single app within itself
um
so i'd like to take
summarize with two other thoughts about
the future um
the first is that there's a lot of
really recent and cool work
uh to provide
uh clusters in the cloud in that the
demonstrations that i provided today are
basically one app or a series about
being sent to individual and separate
cloud workers
and that separation can be a barrier for
really big applications that need to
pass information back and forth to
workers
so there's a new development where cloud
providers are providing virtual clusters
that are linked together
and parallelworks is working on
optimizing these clusters so they have
the same feel and performance as
on-premise clusters
and then finally
the parcel provides a tremendous
flexibility in defining what resources
you want to run
so on the left here is a config file
from a parcel
uh from a in parcel and you'll notice
that there's two resources that are in
here oh i'm sorry
there's
a google cloud provider
and down here there's a slurm provider
and so
if running with this parcel
configuration
[Music]
your workflow you can tell the bash app
decorators to use
the cluster for a specific
uh app
and you can use a different resource for
a different ad
this would be great because it allows
for mix and match and tuning of
resources
uh toward what they're at what they're
running so
if you for example here
a forecast weather forecast model might
run a lot faster on a cluster
but then running the machine learning on
that
weather forecast model would be better
could be better done with a dedicated
gpu
instance in the cloud
so
um so these are these are two
interesting developments that are there
that are on the horizon
so with that i
that's uh i'd be happy to take any
questions you have and uh thank you very
much
thanks steven um does anyone have any
questions you can feel free to mute
yourselves
okay well i won't keep us um
thank you so much steven for
giving us this
talk oh um
anna asks any gpu implementations of
this
so we we've been we've been
yes i have experimented with running a
workflow on a non-gpu machine going to
gpu
and back out
uh
but
it it
so yeah a parcel can run on a gpu or but
it doesn't depend i mean it doesn't
really matter
it's not like it's a specific
implementation there's no specific
library for running parcel from a gpu i
don't think
okay any other questions
okay well thank you so much
um
oh
i just have to keep ending this meeting
more questions sherry if we use aws as
an executor
uh do i need to set up multiple ec2
instances
so it depends entirely on what your what
you need in
for your resources so
uh
for example if you want to use
an instance that is small
you could have two you could have
multiple
instances all set up if you prefer to
send so for example if you want to use
the free tier pricing you can set up a
whole bunch of t2 micros
and and they can work away
um if you instead prefer
to use a single large machine
then then you have that choice in the
configuration
great so asks
do we need or is it preferred that we
set up a parallel works account to take
advantage of the apis
this would be
so to
well you can use par parcel is open
source
uh and available
uh indep you know we contribute to the
parcel project
uh and use parcel on the platform
so
uh
you're but it's not it's not required to
use the parallelworks platform in order
to use parcel is does that is that the
the
the the api the platform has an api
associated with it where you can
interact
with resources defined on the platform
via platform api as well
uh but it's but that's that's a
different matter
sherry if we set up on a local or single
machine is parcel similar to the python
multiprocessing package
uh that's a great question
uh
i
the
i've not used the multi-processing
package
so but i think
my understanding is that it's going to
have the additional benefit of of being
able to track
how things go from one plate one app to
another
uh so they're like parcel will have
more functionality in terms of keeping
track of the app futures
uh than than than a pure
multi-processing
okay
great well
i'm glad we have so many questions come
through at the last minute
um
thank you very much yeah thank you
um we have these meetups monthly uh
usually the last thursday of the month
so uh stay posted for our next meetup
event
thanks everyone thank you very
interesting thanks a lot
thank you